foreign
[Music]
cruelty
you've been fighting the Harkins for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father
my father didn't believe the Revenge
We Believe
beside you
reload
[Music]
he said I got that
thanks
I won't be fighting for him I'm fighting
for my people
[Music]
you young pop
do you believe in Paul
bitter science
why is that a bad thing use it because
of all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paul the tradies are still alive
deal with this prophet
[Music]
tell me who you are
father
was a weak man
look who's back from the dead
no do it must be done
we gave them something to hope for
that's not hard
yeah
I will love you as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave us
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
a trading
Duke Uncle Ruckus
[Music]
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it
[Music]
foreign